hey everyone it's Sarah the registered
nurse rn.com and in this video I'm going
to be reviewing the lung sound known as
pleura friction rub first let's listen
to some audio of what a pleura friction
rub may sound like
now how do you know that you're hearing
a pleura friction rub well you want to
pay attention to the timing with floor
friction rubs they can occur on
inspiration and expiration and they're
going to have a low pitch to them in
addition they can be discontinuous or
continuous it really depends on the
severity of the rub and what's going on
with your patient and it's located in
the pleura layer which are the layers
that surround your lungs which is made
up of the viscera pleura and the
parietal pleura in addition it's going
to have a defining characteristic that
you're going to be able to note on
auscultation you're going to hear this
harsh grading sound in addition your
patient's probably going to have pain
especially when they take deep breaths
in or they cough now let's listen to
that audio of a pleura friction rub
again
foreign
so what causes this sound well it occurs
whenever those plural layers become
inflamed and rub up against each other
because normally the visceral and the
parietal pleura are separated by a small
space so as the patient breathes in
those layers will just Glide over one
another but when those layers become
inflamed that space shrinks which allows
those layers now to rub up against each
other creating pain and that harsh
grating noise that you're going to hear
and it can happen in cases of pleurisy
which just means inflammation of those
pleural layers pneumonia pulmonary
embolism tuberculosis and some forms of
lung cancer okay so that wraps up this
video over pleura friction rub and if
you'd like to watch more videos in this
respiratory series you can access the
link in the YouTube description below